[Music]
and on 17 March 2020
I was hospitalized in
Bergamo Pope John XXiii hospital for
the kobe infection I was sedated and
I don't remember anything until
I woke up in Germany in Almè
around 10 April
I was reading a  po and then I was always waiting
for the phone call from the doctors who
told us how he was when claudio was
hospitalized I found myself here
alone and time passed very slowly they
talked to my family every
day through the interpreter who
organized the video calls
we hope to  to be able to travel back
together as always have a wonderful
holiday for Europe we care a lot
they were very beautiful moments
we hope to be able to continue living
together
[Music]